- Whenever I think of my
favorite flavors of jelly,
grass is seldom in the conversation.
(upbeat music)
- I like jelly.
- I like grass.
- Sounds dope, I like
grass and I like jelly.
- Grass flavored marijuana, maybe.
- Ha, grass.
- (growls)
- Interesting.
- This is not green.
- Oh no.
- (laughs)
- There are chunks in it,
but it does have a, oooh,
does have kind of a
minty smell to it though.
- Looks like coke with
stuff floating in it.
- It smells really good though
- (grunts)
- (laughs)
- So much worse looking than it tastes.
- Tastes like a melon juice.
- Oooh I like that.
- Yea, that's jelly.
- (coughs)
- I think if it wasn't grape
flavored I'd probably love it.
- Was this grape?
- Yea, grape jelly drink
No?
Grass, whatever.
- It's yummy, it's kinda like
lychee at the end, right?
- (gurgles)
- [Man in red jacket] I can't, I can't.
(liquid pouring)
- (shiver)
- Mmm
- It's not actual grass
will narrow my whole world.
- It's not, it's not bad, it's not bad.
Thank you.
- I'll be honest with you, it tastes good,
its just like I can't get over what it is.
- Taylor also does not like grape.